but the president did talk about a
global food shortage because of the
wheat supply that is going to be impact
greatly impacted by this war and this
comes laura as the new fox news poll
shows that 56 percent of americans say
that inflation is not under control at
all obviously because it's at a 40-year
high and it looks like things are
getting even worse
yeah
what what do you want to hear from the
president of the united states i guess
that there is going to be a worldwide
famine really positive to hear from joe
biden but there's one person he could
blame for this he can turn around take a
look in the mirror and blame himself
because
none of this situation guys would have
ever happened if not for the biden bad
energy policies if we would have stayed
with the trump era energy policies
remain energy energy independent as a
country been a net energy exporter
russia would not have had the
stranglehold over europe they wouldn't
have had the money and the leverage to
invade ukraine in this entire situation
would not be happening right now so
obviously it's a horrific thing to hear
that potentially this could impact not
just ukraine but spread it out
throughout the world that people are
going to be starving because of what's
happening between russia and ukraine
right now and you think about the fact
that the entire situation could have
been avoided
about a year ago last april though the
biden administration started paying a
lot of money to farmers here in america
not to farm and of course this isn't an
effort to make everything greener to
limit carbon emissions so perhaps a step
forward in the right direction would be
to say hey let's make some more wheat
here let's plant more crops here let's
let our farmers farm and stop paying
them not to farm and maybe that's an
idea maybe we can help the rest of the
world in that way we have to get back to
producing things here in america and
distributing them around the world
whether it's energy maybe it's crops but
gosh just bad all around more bad
policies and more bad news from the
biden administration yeah the people
seem to understand this it is shocking
why the president does not meantime
former president donald trump who you
know sources tell me is suing hillary
clinton her indicted lawyer jake
sullivan james comey christopher steele
and the dnc for crippling his 2016 race
a lot of people included in this
lara what's his goal with this suit
well we can't have two separate systems
of justice in this country todd and
unfortunately that is exactly what it
has felt like has happened
since donald trump was elected in 2016
we have unmasked so much corruption we
have seen time and time again how things
my father-in-law talked about happening
and he was mocked for saying actually
were proven right that it wasn't that
our campaign was colluding with russia
it was that the dnc and the clinton
campaign was actually colluding with
russia but unfortunately nothing has
been done to the people that spied on
the trump campaign that spied on my
father-in-law um that did all of these
egregious acts which
are just so shocking in america you
would think about this happening in a
banana republic but they happen here in
america to a you know an election that
is arguably the most important in the
entire world so whenever these things
happen and there are no consequences it
should scare every single american so we
want to make sure that people are held
to account that there is one system of
justice and whenever wrongs are
committed that you know there are checks
and balances on that unfortunately none
of these actors have been
called on any of this nothing has
happened to them so we're leaving it to
donald trump again to try and do the
right thing here we'll see what happens
all right more to come on that lawsuit
laura thank you so much for joining us
this morning we always appreciate it
thanks guys hi everyone i'm brian
kilmeade i want you to do me a favor i
want you to click to subscribe to the
fox news youtube page this is the only
way that i know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on fox you can get it
all here on youtube so subscribe right
now